RETO MEIER: Good afternoon,
Everyone.
My name is Reto Meier.
I am the tech lead
on the Android
Developer Relations Team.
And as part of the Android
Developer Relations team, a
lot of our job is to listen to
you guys, ask questions from
these guys, and tell you
guys the answer.
So I thought it may be a little
bit more fun to let you
guys ask them directly.
Still through me, so
that we can keep
everything nice and smooth.
So I thought we'd start
off by having our team
introduce each other.
So at least introduce
themselves, perhaps.
Each other could be fun.
But no.
We'll stick with themselves.
Starting, perhaps, with
Matias at the end.
MATIAS DUARTE: Hi.
My name is Matias Duarte.
And I lead the Android
design team.
RACHEL GARB: Hi.
I'm Rachel Garb.
I'm an interaction designer
on Matias's team.
JEFF HAMILTON: I'm
Jeff Hamilton.
I'm the tech lead for Google
Play services.
ADAM POWELL: I'm Adam Powell.
I'm on the Android
framework team.
REBECCA ZAVIN: I'm
Rebecca Zavin.
I'm on the Android
systems team.
DAN MORRILL: I'm Dan Morrill.
I was recently promoted to
VP of lunch, apparently.
And I'd just like to
say, [? holla ?]
[? y'alla. ?]
DAVE BURKE: Dave Burke.
Eng director for the
Android platform.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: I'm
Ficus Kirkpatrick.
I lead the Play Store team.
ROMAIN GUY: I'm Romain Guy.
I work on the Android
framework team.
XAVIER DUCROHET: I'm
Xavier Ducrohet.
I'm the tech lead for the
SDK and developer tools.
DIANNE HACKBORN: I'm
Dianne Hackborn.
I work on the Android
framework team.
RETO MEIER: All right.
Thanks, everyone.
So the purpose of the fireside
chat is really for you guys to
be able to interact with some
of the people which actually
build the stuff that we
often talk about.
So it is really about
interactions.
And we've got a couple of
microphones set up, if you
guys want to start lining up
to ask your questions.
I'm going to start off with a
few things which we tend to
get asked a lot in developer
relations.
So I thought rather than making
up my own answers, I
would give these guys
the opportunity to
respond for a change.
So one thing which I get asked
a lot is, Android is a really
big project.
It certainly hasn't gotten any
smaller over the years.
So a lot of independent
developers wonder, how do you
continue to maintain that same
sort of velocity without
sacrificing quality?
DAVE BURKE: I just depend on
really smart people over here
to do good work.
I don't know.
That's a really good question.
We do planning around
releases.
So we think about what we want
to do in the release.
We survey across
the whole team.
We try to come up with
themes for what we're
trying to work on.
Like in Jelly Bean, and we try
to work on jank, et cetera.
And really it's just about
rallying the team around that.
And a lot of the engineers and
UX folks and product managers
on Android are just very
passionate about what they do.
And they want to build the best
possible product, full of
energy, and really smart, and
yeah, it's as simple as that.
The other thing I would say
is, the industry is very
competitive.
And it's changing
all the time.
And something we do in Android
is, we try to be very agile.
So we constantly evaluate where
we are, where we're
weakest, where we're stronger.
And adjust our plans to that.
And I think that helps with
our velocity as well.
Because we're kind of
very self aware
of where we're going.
ROMAIN GUY: I think what he
meant was, he keeps us chained
to our desks, really.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
That's true.
RETO MEIER: Thanks, Dave.
I've got a follow-up
question for that.
But first, we're going to answer
the questions from you
guys at the front.
But I'd encourage everyone else
who lines up to do so at
the back mic so that we don't
have heads in the video.
So the follow-up was, given
the velocity, the speed at
which the Android team is
developing new frameworks, is
there anything that you would
have done differently?
Like, looking back at the things
which have launched,
and some of those choices,
anything if you had a little
bit more time, you could
go back and change?
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: How
much time do we have?
RETO MEIER: You could get
about 36 minutes.
DIANNE HACKBORN: I think-- and
you probably won't like this.
But I think probably the biggest
thing that we should
have done differently in a few
places was, there's a few
places where we should have
had more control over
applications.
Like, a good example is the
whole settings provider.
The applications go
in right to it.
Which was just a simple thing
that we shouldn't have done.
And those kind of things, where
you let applications do
things, are really hard
to get away from.
So it takes a long time to clean
up that kind of stuff.
There's lots of things that
you look back, and you're
like, yeah, that could have
been done better.
But usually it's implementation,
or even APIs
are pretty easy to change.
But when it's things that you
let applications do that
you're like, maybe we shouldn't
have done that,
those are really hard
to recover from.
RETO MEIER: Any other takers?
Ficus, did you want to
add anything to that?
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: Well, I was
just talking a little trash
about content providers
to Jeff.
Yeah.
There's a long list.
I think you're never going
to get everything
right the first time.
And I don't really regret any
of the mistakes we've made.
Because I think getting things
out there at the speed we did
and having the opportunity to
get the feedback and iterate
was actually the most
important thing.
RETO MEIER: So I'm going to
ask one question which was
asked by a G+, by Peter
van der Linden on
exactly this topic.
And he suggested that the binder
software for Android
IPC is now in its third
implementation after
BOS and Palm OS.
And he asks, are you any closer
to getting it right?
So that may be a little
bit inflammatory.
So let me ask you this.
Are you happy with the Android
IPC binder implementation?
Is there anything that you would
do differently if you
got a fourth attempt to do it?
DIANNE HACKBORN: I mean, you
never ever get anything
perfectly right, so--
well.
We're happy with it.
And I think the phrasing of
that is very misleading,
because it wasn't that it was
changed because we weren't
happy with what we had before.
But it was rewritten to address
the needs each time.
And for Android, we had a very
different environment, where
it was really just used for IPC
instead of the previous
version, which was built around
C++ and had a lot
dynamic language features that
don't exist in C++, so we
built them up ourselves.
And once we moved over to
Android, we were doing that in
Java, and all that dynamic part
of it just didn't make
sense, which of the Java
language already having a lot
of those features.
So the right thing to do is go
and look at, what do we need
now, and build what makes sense
for what you need then.
RETO MEIER: Perfect.
All right.
So you guys have been
waiting patiently.
Starting at the front,
perhaps.
What's your question?
ERIC GRAY: Hi.
I'm Eric Gray from Canada,
Vancouver.
My main question was about
Android updates.
And I know that there's been
an awful lot of talk about
fragmentation--
the F-word for Android.
And I know that it has
vastly improved
in the latest versions.
But there's still a gross
number of people
using 2.2 and 2.3.
And as you guys said at one of
the previous I/Os, you have
been working with the OEMs to
make the update process a lot
faster and smoother,
but no one really
is seeing this change.
So is there still a continued
effort in this area?
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
Very good question.
This is something we think
about a lot, actually.
There's multiple levels to it.
If you think about what we do,
we release open source.
And then Silicon vendors take
that open source, and then
they bring it up on their
particular SOC.
And they create what
they call a BSP.
Then they have the
BSP to the OEM.
And then the OEM produces
a phone.
And so there's this big channel
before an actual
update gets out.
So we're doing a lot of things
internally, thinking about how
we can actually streamline
that process.
Part of it is making the actual
code for the platform
more layered so that if a
Silicon vendor needs to make
changes, they have a very clean
abstraction layer to do that.
So we're looking to
streamline it.
The other thing we're looking at
is to try to understand the
hardware profile of different
devices running different
Android versions.
So there is a predominance of
Gingerbread in emerging
markets, for example.
And one of the reasons for that
is because it runs on
lower memory than some of the
newer Android versions.
And it's not so much the system,
but actually the
applications themselves
tend to be more
advanced and richer.
And so we're looking at ways to
make Android more efficient
for the sort of entry-level
smartphone as well, to help
improve that situation.
MATIAS DUARTE: I want to jump
in also on the other end to
reaffirm how important updates
are for Android, and how we
really are working in lots
of different ways.
And the relationships with our
OEM partners are really
important to us.
Sometimes it can seem like you
don't see a lot of that.
But it is a very complex
problem for them.
It matters a lot to us.
We are working on it.
One small sign of our efforts
there is what we announced
yesterday, the Galaxy S4, that
has the Nexus software
experience and will have
more timely updates.
ERIC GRAY: Thank
you very much.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
From the back.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering for NDK
developers that want to
exploit multicore parallelism,
are you doing anything there
in terms of new capabilities?
Or are there existing
tools or libraries
that you would recommend?
ROMAIN GUY: We use threads.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: That's
a good answer.
Very thorough.
ROMAIN GUY: OK.
To be fair, the NDK is pretty
simple, and we know it's
difficult to use.
And that probably won't make you
feel better, but it's not
that much better for us when
we write native code.
I've been writing way
too much native code
these past two years.
And we don't have anything in
particular that you don't have
when it comes to multi-threading
or using
multiple cores.
Downloadable APIs, I think they
are exposed in the NDK
where you can create a number
of cores, and then you can
make your decisions
based on that.
But maybe Dianne knows more.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
Again from the front.
DANIEL: Hi.
My name is Daniel.
I have a question regarding
the navigational drawer.
It was mentioned in the session
that one of the
advantages is that you can
access it from anywhere from
your application.
But shouldn't that actually be
only accessible from your root
activities, or the top-level
activities?
And the reason I'm asking is,
if you allow the user to
access the navigation drawer
anywhere from your
application, like categories
and details, wouldn't that
just keep adding more and more
and more activities to the
stack and then make it kind of
hard for the user to remember
what the back button or the up
button is going to do, since
they have now an infinite
number of
activities on the stack?
MATIAS DUARTE: I'll take
that one just to
jump in real quick.
Which is, if you're just adding
activities onto the
stack without regard for your
app's structure, you're not
doing it right.
ADAM POWELL: To go a little
bit deeper on that--
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: No, I think
we're done there.
No.
Please.
ADAM POWELL: So if you do use
the navigation drawer at
deeper levels of your
application, then you should
treat some of those navigation
targets the same way that you
would treat either a
notification or a widget
coming from another part
of your application.
So go ahead and just replace the
full tasks stack to build
something that makes sense
for that destination.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
RETO MEIER: I guess while
we've got the designers
talking, I had a couple
of other questions
which have come up.
So there's a lot of people
getting involved in the world
of design for the first time,
largely because of all the
talks we give at I/O and how
much importance we say that
there is around it.
So what are some of the tools
that you guys use within the
Android team to design the
platform user experience?
And to follow on from that as
well, where are some of the
places you get your
inspiration from?
I think a lot of the people
here get their inspiration
from what we do.
So where do you guys get
that inspiration
from to begin with?
RACHEL GARB: I think one of our
most important tools is
our studio where we sit
together in an open
environment.
So we're always talking
with each other.
And we have such an
eclectic group.
I think that everybody
gets inspiration
from different things.
I've seen people share
architecture, designs of cars,
sci-fi movies, Matias's
shirts, you know.
It could come from anywhere.
So I think just being together
and sharing a lot and bouncing
ideas off each other not only
provides inspiration, but is
also a big tool for us in terms
of how we work together.
Because the more input that we
get on our designs, the better
it gets each time we refine.
Anything to add?
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
Let's see.
I think we're up to the back.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So Android
SDK recommends the
use of the JDK 1.6.
That has been, at this point,
officially end-of-lifed.
And large corporations--
help desks-- like to push
out updates to say,
oh, get rid of this.
Is the Android SDK going
to be moving to 1.7?
Or what's the roadmap there?
DAVE BURKE: So we're
investigating, looking at a
couple of options.
Haven't made any
decisions yet.
So I don't have anything
to announce.
But we're aware of that.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Wait, was the
question about running the
tools on a host JDK 1.7?
AUDIENCE: Running the compiler,
running the SDK.
XAVIER DUCROHET: So to run the
host tools now, you can run
them on 1.7.
That was an issue before, where
signing didn't actually
work if you have a
JDK 7 installed.
But we fixed that in
21.2, I think.
So you can do proper signing now
directly if you use 7 on
your host computer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
RETO MEIER: And from
the front.
DREW: Hi.
My name is Drew.
And I'm asking this question
both as an Android user and as
a developer.
I wonder what thoughts and
considerations have gone in
the platform for having
optional application
permissions.
So, say my application must
have this group of five
permissions, but for these
features, if you want to use
this feature, you'll have to
grant us access to these
applications.
And a perfect example is, I've
been using an app called
Pocket, which I really enjoy.
They added a recent update
which wanted
access to my contacts.
And it set off my inner tinfoil
hat a little bit.
ADAM POWELL: I haven't installed
that update either.
DIANNE HACKBORN: There have
certainly been a lot of
thoughts put into this.
There's nothing that we can
commit to doing right now.
But we're definitely thinking
about this.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
So another question.
Going out a little bit
deeper this time.
So Android runs on a huge
variety of hardware.
And we do new platforms and new
devices quite regularly.
Can anyone comment on what was
the most challenging chipset
or device to bring up?
REBECCA ZAVIN: All of them?
No.
I think the most challenging
was probably the first one.
Because we were starting
from scratch.
If you look today, as Dave was
pointing out, our Silicon
vendors consume the Android
framework and
come up with a BSP.
They all have BSPs now that they
provide that run Android.
But when we started on the
G1, there was nothing.
And there was not really
Linux support
on Qualcomm's hardware.
So that was definitely
the most challenging.
I think in an ongoing way, it's
more challenging when
we're the first to a
new architecture.
So if you look at something like
the Nexus 10, that was
one of the first devices to ship
on the newest ARM design.
And obviously, there are the
usual challenges of being an
early adopter.
So I think that's probably the
most challenging, is when
we're the first to a new CPU
architecture, a new GPU
architecture.
And you always experience some
of the pain of little bugs and
just new features that you
have to figure out
how to make use of.
DAVE BURKE: We work pretty
closely with all of the
Silicon partners.
Just give you an example of
how that works, so with
Hardware Composer, which is
used for accelerating
composition, we'll come up when
a new design for that.
And then we'll work with the
likes of Qualcomm, Nvidia, et
cetera, ARM, and say, hey, look,
here's the new interface
that we want to implement.
What do you think of it?
And then they'll give us
feedback and say, oh that's
really hard for us to
do on one chipset.
Or another chipset might say,
well, it'll work on us, but
it's not performing.
What if you tweak it this way?
And so we do a lot of iteration
in that respect, so
that we try to build a system
so that it works really well
on a broad range of hardware.
We don't always get it right.
And we have to iterate.
And you'll see that in our
hardware layers, that we're
often iterating and
improving them.
But our goal is to make Android
work well across a
variety of different hardware
and make it easy for OEMs to
bring up devices quickly.
RETO MEIER: So following on from
that, you said the first
one was the hardest.
And obviously, there's been
a lot of changes.
The pace of mobile device
improvement has been quite
staggering.
Do you think we've
plateaued now?
Is all the hard work
behind us?
No new chips, no new sensors.
Are we kind of done, or not?
DAVE BURKE: No.
I don't know.
I feel like Android's a baby.
I feel like there's so
much more we can do.
I think there's new--
if you actually just look at
the power, it's only really
this year that GPUs have gotten
powerful enough that
they can actually think about
doing something other than
draw the screen.
Like, so actually do computation
on the GPU.
And so that's kind of opening
up whole other doors.
We have a language called
RenderScript that allows you
to target C Kernels
to the GPU.
We're seeing lots of new
peripherals appear.
I think the Samsung Galaxy
S4 has an IR
transmitter, for example.
I think camera is an area
that can really
do with more evolution.
If you think about a camera on
a phone, it's basically tries
to emulate a digital camera,
which tries to emulate an old
analog Kodak-type camera.
But there's so much more you
can do, not just at the
software level, but at the
hardware level as well.
So I think there's going to be
lot of innovation across the
board for many years to come.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Thanks.
I think we're up to the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We've been trying to
get Android into
health care and hospitals.
And we found that there's a big
existing investment in iOS
apps that are custom
apps, native apps.
Wondered if you had any advice
on more cost-effective ways to
help them port that.
And specifically wondered
whether you guys had ever
thought about trying to help
start a open-source clean-room
iOS emulator for Android.
Let's say that the apps
are relatively simple.
Let's say that the tablets
are enterprise-owned.
It would be kind of like
Wine for Linux.
But iOS apps on Android.
RETO MEIER: Do we have anyone
from legal here who
can answer this one?
DAVE BURKE: Well, I was thinking
we should go up to
Cupertino and ask them
to start emulating
Android apps, actually.
Much better.
RETO MEIER: Anyone want to touch
that with a barge pole?
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: It seems
like a lot of work for a
pretty sub-optimal
user experience.
I don't think that would
be very interesting.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I think that's
generally our approach.
To encourage everyone to try
and build the best possible
Android apps rather than trying
to figure out how to
get apps from other platforms
to run on it.
AUDIENCE: It's just in the real
world, if you have 1,000
apps that you've already written
that are native,
moving those would cost hundreds
of developer-years.
So any transition strategy--
if anybody has a different
idea, that would
be great, too.
But it's a real problem we're
trying to struggle with in
figuring out how to make Android
app devices work in
that field.
MATIAS DUARTE: This sounds like
an opportunity for all
the developers here to write
some health-care-focused apps.
RETO MEIER: There's
1,000 developer
hours' worth of work.
So there's definitely
an opportunity.
ROMAIN GUY: So I probably
shouldn't mention that, but
one of my co-workers recently
told me that games that are
ported from iOS to Android,
they use--
I don't remember the name
of the framework.
But someone rewrote the iOS UI
tookit with OpenGL on Android.
So that might be
a way to do it.
It's probably bad for
the user experience.
But you could try.
RETO MEIER: Thanks.
OK.
So we've also got a couple of
questions from folks watching
on the live stream from Google
I/O Extended events.
This one's for Ficus.
In Volley, if you implement a
download huge image, then
resize to fit your needs, will
the original image be cached
in disk cache, or
the resized one?
FICUS KIRKPATRICK:
Hang on a second.
RETO MEIER: I can repeat
the question.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: They're
asking about the disk cache?
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: OK.
The original one goes to the
disk cache, and the smaller
one goes in the memory cache.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Simple.
Up at the front, please.
TOBIAS: My name is Tobias
from Sweden.
I have a framework-specific
question.
Basically I'm wondering, if
you use a [? contentive ?]
server for to serve--
observe SQLite stuff, you get
millions of on content change.
And I've always been curious
why you get so many.
JEFF HAMILTON: I think you get
one when the content changes.
If you're getting a million
notifications that the
content's changed--
TOBIAS: Always not a million,
but always, when I try to
observe data, and let's say one
item is inserted, I always
get at least 10, 15, 20.
And I have to put in a throttle
or something to--
JEFF HAMILTON: So the content
provider that you're observing
is responsible for sending
the notifications.
And if you're getting a
significant amount of them,
either the content provider is
sending more than it should,
and it should be aggregated.
Or, more likely, you probably
should be using transactions.
If you have a database, you
should be using a transaction.
And if you're putting in a
significant amount of data at
once, use a transaction.
And then at the end of the
transaction, when the full
transaction is committed, then
the content provider should
send a change notification at
that point, as opposed to one
for each thing that's
happening within the
transaction.
TOBIAS: So you can change
your content provider?
JEFF HAMILTON: Yeah.
Each content provider is
responsible for sending those
notifications.
So it really depends on which
content provider you're using
and how the data is being
manipulated by whatever's
modifying the data itself.
TOBIAS: All right.
Thank you.
RETO MEIER: From the back.
THOMAS: I'm Thomas from
Mountain View.
I have a question regarding
Google Play services.
You've announced at I/O in the
past few months new APIs like
Google+ Sign-In, and new
GCM features as well.
Do you plan to push
more APIs through
the Google Play services?
I guess it's good for
developers, because you get
the new API ready
really quick.
But you also see it as a way for
OEMs not to use their own
store because they want
the developers to get
your service as well?
JEFF HAMILTON: To the first
part, I think if you've been
watching what we've been doing
with Google Play services, we
have been steadily increasing
the number of APIs that we
have included.
And we had a significant number
of new releases with
the latest release
that went out.
Before that, we added
in the apps.
And we've been adding pretty
quickly the new API sets.
And we certainly have
more work to do.
I don't know.
Ficus, do you want to talk
about the store part?
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: I'll
take the second part.
I don't think there's anything
about Google Play services
that keeps people from doing
their own stores.
Amazon app store still
works totally fine.
THOMAS: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: So, we've had a lot
of pretty easy questions.
I'm going to ask you a couple
of tougher ones.
So I think everyone's looking
forward to the possibility of
tasting some pie.
Now, I know well enough not
to ask you about anything
specific there.
But on behalf of our Australian
audience, which I
feel like I represent, I wanted
to know if any of you
have ever tried a Lamington.
And if so, what you
thought about it.
Lamingtons, anyone?
No?
No one's even been
to Australia.
You don't even know
what I mean.
DAVE BURKE: The teleprompter
translated that as
"lankington." So a kind
of tall dessert.
What is a Lamington?
RETO MEIER: People don't know
what a Lamington is either.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: What is it?
MATIAS DUARTE: Is
it a meat pie?
Is it made out of sheep?
RETO MEIER: I'll bring some
to work some time.
AUDIENCE: It's sponge
covered in
chocolate with some coconut.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: I've
had a Tim Tam Slam.
DAVE BURKE: A Tim Tam Slam.
What's a Tim Tam Slam?
Is that a cocktail
with Tim Tam?
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: [INAUDIBLE]
with tea.
DAVE BURKE: With tea?
Oh, that's boring.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK:
No, it's good.
DAVE BURKE: Oh.
RETO MEIER: All right.
I think we should go
back to the crowd.
From the front, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Savas from London.
This is a question related to
the question that was asked of
Larry Page in the keynote.
And sort of related
to a question
that was asked before.
It's related to Oracle
and Java.
Are we ever going to see Java
7 or Java 8 compliance on
Android, and taking advantage
of the new features that are
implemented?
Not just the language-level
features, but fork
join, stuff like that.
DAN MORRILL: I don't
think we can--
I know I can't comment
on that, anyway.
DAVE BURKE: I want to
know what Larry
said to that question.
AUDIENCE: It wasn't specifically
a question about
the features of Java 7
or 8 and if we are
going to get them.
It was more of a question of the
relationship with Oracle.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
I'll second what Dan said.
RETO MEIER: I think it's fair
to say that no one on this
panel should have an opinion.
And if they do, they certainly
shouldn't say it.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: So I'm going to
throw in another question.
So, having watched the Bluetooth
best practices talk,
it seems like we've changed
the Bluetooth
stack quite a few times.
I was wondering if any of you
could explain why that is.
Why have we got the multiple
Bluetooth implementations?
DAVE BURKE: We changed
it once.
Not a few times.
RETO MEIER: It may have been
a couple of times.
DAVE BURKE: Since I got here.
But I think, in total,
in lifetime.
So we recently changed from
Blue Z to Blue Droid.
And one of the reasons we did
that was mostly because Jay
Kumar just wanted to do it.
He was bored one day, and he's
like, hey, look at this.
But the reason he told me he
wanted to do it was that he
felt that the new stack was a
little bit more efficient for
embedded devices.
So the previous stack depended
on DBUS and GLIB, which were
never really designed
for embedded.
So that's one reason.
Also, we were seeing a lot of
people in the industry,
particularly Silicon folks,
using this stack.
And so we were to that point I
said earlier about trying to
streamline.
It was sort of a path
of least resistance
to adopt that stack.
And it's enabled to
do new things.
So we announced yesterday that
we're going to be supporting
Bluetooth LE in the
upcoming release.
RETO MEIER: Thanks.
From the back.
TAM: I'm Tam from Japan.
I have a hope about Brutus.
I'm imprinting a Dial-Up Network
profile by software.
But Japanese Android often have
DUN profile already, and
those ones cannot receive
the connection of DUN.
So I want to handle service
discovery profile.
So would you implement that?
SPEAKER: That's a
good question.
It's so good I can't
answer it.
Actually, if you come to office
hours tomorrow, we'll
try to find somebody who can
answer that for you.
TAM: OK.
Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
From the front.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is [INAUDIBLE]
from Portugal.
With all the emerging pattern
that we've seen--
Facebook, and Currents, and with
Left Drawer, and now with
the Navigation Drawer--
it seems like the Up pattern
is getting faded out.
Because a lot of the apps don't
implement it well, when
a lot of the users don't know
actually that's there is an Up
and not the Back.
So how do you see the Up
pattern with the new
navigation drawer?
MATIAS DUARTE: OK.
I'll start with that.
And Adam can chime
in if he likes.
So we actually think that
there is definitely a
continued use for
Up navigation.
Not every application, for
starters, is well-suited by
having a side drawer
for navigation.
It's simply not applicable for
anything that doesn't have
that kind of deep hierarchy.
Second of all, it's actually
not a good way to replace a
single step going up
in a hierarchy.
And as you know, that
is not always the
same use case as Back.
And simply abandoning that would
actually force you to
always take a 2-step navigation
through the
drawer-- which would be bad--
or would put you in a
potentially temporally
ambiguous action when you've
deep-linked from other places
as to what Back would do.
So we're in no way deprecating
the Up pattern.
And if you look at the Android
Design Guide, you'll see some
very specific guidelines on when
you should be using that
and when you should be using
the side drawer.
And I think if you've got any
questions about the details of
that, you should stop by office
hours, and we can try
to clarify that.
AUDIENCE: The main question is
because when you click, it
automatically opens or closes
the navigation.
And that might confuse
some users that are
used to the Up button.
MATIAS DUARTE: No, we've found
quite the opposite.
We've found that, actually,
having it have a distinct
affordance that's animated makes
it very clear to users
that they're not going to go
up, that it provides a
different affordance.
ADAM POWELL: And you can also
see these two things working
together in the new update
to the play music app.
If you drill down into, for
example, one of the artist or
album pages, you can see that
even though the Up affordance
is available, that you can still
pull out the drawer and
do a quick link to another part
of the app if you choose.
RETO MEIER: So I have a
follow-up question.
Why does the Up affordance point
to the left instead of
pointing up?
ADAM POWELL: It started
off pointing up, and
then no one saw it.
RETO MEIER: Is that right?
No one saw it?
ADAM POWELL: The first
release of Honeycomb.
It started pointing up
to the upper left.
RETO MEIER: There you go.
Mystery's answered.
From the back.
LEI: Hi.
My name is Lei.
I have two quick questions
about Android video
technologies.
The first is, are you guys
considering any evolution to
Video Player like SpotDash, the
new video stream protocol,
or subtitling or closed
captioning?
And the second question is, what
will be your focus in the
short term and the mid term
for the Android video
technologies?
Thanks.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
Good question.
So first one, are we
supporting Dash?
We did a lot of work in the
previous release to introduce
a lot of low-level APIs to
enable people to write their
own streaming clients that may
be based on HLS or Dash.
So we introduced MediaCodec,
Media Extractor, Crypto, and
there's another one which I
didn't want to mention because
we haven't released it yet.
So we've done a lot of work in
the low level to enable that.
We're seeing a lot of
interest in Dash.
It's probably something we're
going to introduce
over time, for sure.
In the meantime, with the
low-level APIs, you can
actually create your
own Dash player.
So we actually really
anticipate seeing
developers do that.
Closed captioning is something
we're looking at also.
I think that would be good.
To your point about the second
part of your question, where
are we going.
I mean, personally, I think
we should invest more in
low-level APIs to allow
developers--
historically, we have this very
high-level media player.
You give it a URL.
It's too high-level for
some use cases.
So we want to invest
in low-level APIs.
And then I think we also want
to invest in streaming
technologies like HLS, which we
already have, and Dash, and
closed captioning, and
things like that.
RETO MEIER: Thanks, Dave.
So last year we talked a lot
about Project Butter, our
effort to remove jank
from Android.
Are we done there?
Is that mission accomplished?
Or is that still an
ongoing project?
DAVE BURKE: It's very much
an ongoing project.
I really want to pass
this microphone.
Someone else should talk.
I think Romain should talk.
ROMAIN GUY: Whom
are you joking?
I want you to say
we were done.
DAVE BURKE: Mission acc-
MALE SPEAKER: NO.
DAVE BURKE: We have a team.
Romain and I meet every
week working
specifically on this issue.
We made a lot of progress
in Jelly Bean.
But I still think there's
a lot more we can do.
We're not at the level that
I think we could be.
I think part of it is when you
take a Nexus 4 or something
like that, you're kind
of spoiled by the
power of the GPU.
And you have to really think--
you really need to
test on multiple
different levels of devices.
That 16.66 millisecond
window is critical.
If you miss that, you
jank, as we say.
Which basically means you'll
see frame-skipping.
And so it's critical that we
make sure that all our
applications are efficient and
adhering to that, et cetera.
But it's something we
constantly work at.
Romain's--
ROMAIN GUY: It's not something
we can ever be done with.
Every time we write new features
and applications on
the framework, we have to make
sure that the new code doesn't
impact performance.
So we've done all that work
in Project Butter, in 4.1.
And in 4.2, we had a
new round of that.
And we're constantly doing it.
We'll never, never, ever stop.
And I'll keep finding bugs for
the application developers
until they get it right.
RETO MEIER: So one of the things
which really excited me
about Project Butter
was, it was
across the entire framework.
Is there any other projects
which you're able to talk
about which have the same
sort of holistic view of
everything?
DAVE BURKE: Yes, but you
can't talk about them.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes to the first.
No to the second.
DAVE BURKE: Ficus said I
have to stop talking.
DIANNE HACKBORN: In Froyo, we
had this thing on bundling
that was actually--
so Android, from the start, was
really designed to have an
open-source platform
parts that's--
everyone's open.
They can modify.
And has all the infrastructure
for building all
your services on top.
And Google Services were
what we targeted.
And to get at one point all that
out in the time we did,
we cut a few corners on the
Google step and didn't really
build against the SDK and
do all the right stuff.
So in Froyo, we had a big effort
to basically take all
the Google Apps, make them
really build on top of the
SDK, and clean up all that
stuff and put all
the pieces in place.
And that involved lots of
work from the app team.
Also, in the framework,
we had to--
if there were things we needed
in the framework and
everything, to put those in.
And that has been what has
allowed us to do Google Play
services, and basically deliver
a lot of new features
to existing platforms
through stuff from
Google and other places.
Oh, yes.
And--
ROMAIN GUY: And there was this
thing called Honeycomb.
We added support for tablets.
That was a lot of work.
40 apps.
A lot of work for a framework.
That was a huge thing
for everybody.
And we all worked together
on that.
RETO MEIER: Thanks.
Let's see.
From the front.
AUDIENCE: It's great to see
y'all here for another I/O.
And it's good to see
some new faces.
Us Android users and
developers, we're
kind of a vocal lot.
We complain a lot.
RETO MEIER: No.
AUDIENCE: And there are
lots of issues.
We enter lots of comments.
Some of them not so kind.
ROMAIN GUY: We complain
a lot too, internally.
Don't worry.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted us to
pause for a second and applaud
for all the great work that this
team has done over the
years for us.
[APPLAUSE]
RETO MEIER: Do we have any other
questions like that?
AUDIENCE: I have one
little complaint--
FICUS KIRKPATRICK:
More of this guy.
AUDIENCE: --or comment
or something.
We've been using Android since
Version 1 with Eclipse as a
development system.
And some people have even
written entire books
on how to do that.
So I'm wondering what the
reasons were, and the thought
behind going in this new
direction with IntelliJ.
RETO MEIER: There's a lot of
us who have to do a lot of
extra writing because
of this, so it'd
better be a good answer.
ROMAIN GUY: It's not
a new direction.
It's just a parallel
direction.
You can still use Eclipse, and
we'll keep supporting Eclipse.
A lot of developers told us
that they wanted to use
IntelliJ because
they prefer it.
We should support those
developers and help them make
applications.
If you aren't Eclipse users,
you should try IntelliJ.
Maybe you'll like it better.
If you don't, keep
using Eclipse.
That's perfectly fine.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
It's funny.
It's actually--
no, please.
Clap.
I was going to say, It's
actually funny.
Because it was one of the
questions we used to get early
on, was why do you only
support Eclipse?
When are we going
to get support
for things like IntelliJ?
So it makes sense that
we've now expanded to
include more things.
ADAM POWELL: It's Android,
not Ordroid.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN MORRILL: I'LL also say,
years and years ago--
well, I guess maybe not
I remember when IntelliJ
was first open-sourced.
I happen to be one of those
people who prefers IntelliJ.
So I found Zav and I said, hey
Zav, now that IntelliJ's
open-source, when are
you switching to it?
And he said, once
Eclipse is done.
RETO MEIER: Right.
We're almost out of time.
I think we have time for a
couple more questions.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to update the Google Play
developer console to support
multiple users for a single
developer account with
varying privileges?
For example, to create a
developer account that only
has access to see
crash reports?
Or another public relations
account that could only reply
to app store reviews?
Because right now, sharing a
single developer console
account with a large team
is kind of scary.
It's super user-access-ish.
[APPLAUSE]
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: Thank
you for the applause.
But--
RETO MEIER: All you have to
do is pick up the mic.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: The developer
console does support
multiple users and
multiple roles.
If your question is particularly
around
restricting access to crash
reports, or something like
that, then we're not done with
all of the levels of access
that we have.
But we do have the foundations
of that today.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
I think that's fundamentally
the answer is,
we're working on it.
You've seen the velocity that
the developer console team
have been working at is
pretty staggering.
There's a whole bunch of stuff
they released this year for
I/O. They're not slowing
down anytime soon.
So expect to see more
in the future.
So we have about 30
seconds to go.
Have you got a very
quick question?
CHANDRA: Yeah.
OK.
Hi.
I am Chandra.
I have a question on the
presentation framework that
came up in Jelly Bean, which
is supporting secondary
display support.
So today, one application can
hover over two displays.
But is there any plan to
support two independent
displays, one on the local
display, and the other one on
the connector display?
And if so, how is the navigation
works, because the
monitors are not touch screen?
So keyboard and mouse support,
or is there any vision that
you guys have for the
presentation?
RETO MEIER: You lied.
That was not a very
short question.
We'll need a very
short answer.
DIANNE HACKBORN: So the
presentation framework itself
is very flexible, and you can
actually today have lots of
displays and that
kind of stuff.
We completely punted on any
kind of input or anything,
even in the current thing.
The secondary display
is just a display.
Maybe in the future, but that's
not currently part of
the feature set.
RETO MEIER: We are completely
out of time.
Thank you very much to everyone
who asked a question,
and thank you to the panel.
[APPLAUSE]